>>> GOOD EVENING.
I'M ERIN BURNETT.
OUTFRONT TONIGHT, DECERTIFY THE
ELECTION.
THAT IS THE DEMAND COMING FROM
NONE OTHER THAN THE FORMER
PRESIDENT, DONALD TRUMP, AND IT
COMES IN A NEW LETTER TO
GEORGIA'S SECRETARY OF STATE,
BRAD RAFFENSPERGER.
THE SECRETARY IS OUTFRONT
EXCLUSIVELY TONIGHT TO RESPOND
FOR THE FIRST TIME TO TRUMP'S
NEW ATTEMPT TO OVERTURN THE
RESULTS OF THE ELECTION NEARLY
11 MONTHS AFTER THE ELECTION.
SO TRUMP CLAIMS IN HIS LETTER
THAT THERE IS A NEW REPORT OF
INVALID BALLOTS AND SAYS, QUOTE,
I WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
THAT YOUR DEPARTMENT CHECK THIS
AND, IF TRUE, ALONG WITH MANY
OTHER CLAIMS OF VOTER FRAUD AND
VOTER IRREGULARITIES, START THE
PROCESS OF DECERTIFYING THE
ELECTION OR WHATEVER THE CORRECT
LEGAL REMEDY IS AND ANNOUNCE THE
TRUE WINNER.
THAT LETTER WAS SENT THREE DAYS
AGO.
THE ELECTION RESULTS AND BEEN
CERTIFIED AND AUDITS AGAIN AND
AGAIN AND THE TRUE WINNER IS
STILL JOE BIDEN.
TRUMP DID NOT WIN 321 DAYS AGO
IN GEORGIA, AND THERE HAS BEEN
ZERO EVIDENCE SINCE TO CHANGE
THAT.
IN FACT, IN GEORGIA, JUST THE
STATE OF GEORGIA ALONE, THEY
HAVE PERFORMED THREE RECOUNTS
AND NUMEROUS INVESTIGATIONS.
SO NOT ONLY IS THE LETTER
BASELESS, BUT IT AGAIN SHOWS
THAT TRUMP DOESN'T CARE AT ALL
ABOUT THE RULE OF LAW.
IN FACT, HE REFERS TO JOE BIDEN
AS AN ILLEGITIMATE PRESIDENT.
NOW, THERE IS ALREADY AN ONGOING
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION INTO
TRUFRM'S EARLIER ATTEMPTS TO
PRESSURE RAFFENSPERGER TO
OVERTURN THE ELECTION.
IF YOU DON'T REMEMBER WHY, YOU
MAY WANT TO REFRESH YOUR MEMORY.
.PARTLY BECAUSE OF THIS CALL.
>> ALL I WANT TO DO IS THIS.
I JUST WANT TO FIND 11,780
VOTES, WHICH IS ONE MORE THAN WE
HAVE, BECAUSE WE WON THE STATE.
>> NO, HE DID NOT WIN THE STATE.
OUTFRONT NOW, THE REPUBLICAN
SECRETARY OF STATE OF GEORGIA,
BRAD RAFFENSPERGER, WHO IS ALSO
THE AUTHOR OF AN UPCOMING BOOK
ABOUT THE ELECTION AND WHAT HE
WENT THROUGH IN STANDING UP TO
TRUMP FOR THE FACTS ON THE VOTE.
HIS BOOK IS CALLED "INTEGRITY
COUNTS."
SECRETARY RAFFENSPERGER, I
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME TALKING TO
YOU ABOUT THIS.
THIS THE FIRST TIME YOU'RE
COMMENTING ON THIS NEW LETTER
FROM THE PRESIDENT, IN WHICH HE
REFERS TO JOE BIDEN AS AN
ILLEGITIMATE PRESIDENT.
WHAT WAS YOUR INITIAL REACTION
WHEN YOU READ THE LETTER?
>> GOOD EVENING, ERIN.
THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
WELL, I'M A LIFELONG REPUBLICAN.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, I HAVE TO
ALWAYS PUT, YOU KNOW, MY DUTY TO
THE CONSTITUTION AND TO OUR
COUNTRY ABOVE ALL.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, WE'VE
DONE AUDITS.
WE'VE DONE INVESTIGATIONS AND
SOME OF THOSE ARE STILL ONGOING,
SO I CAN'T COMMENT ON THOSE.
BUT VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN DID
CARRY THE STATE OF GEORGIA.
>> SO LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT THE
TIMING HERE.
YOU GOT THIS LETTER THREE DAYS
AGO.
THE ELECTION WAS 321 DAYS AGO.
WERE YOU EVEN GIVEN WHAT HE SAID
TO YOU ON THE PHONE, EVEN GIVEN
THE THINGS HE SAID BEFORE, WERE
YOU SURPRISED TO RECEIVE THIS
LETTER THREE DAYS AGO?
>> I THINK AT SOME LEVEL HE MUST
KNOW THAT HE DID LOSE THE
ELECTION BECAUSE HIS ADVISERS,
HIS LAWYERS TOLD HIM THAT HE
LOST THE ELECTION.
IN FACT, BOOKS ARE COMING OUT
THAT TOLD HIM WHERE THE POLLING
WAS COMING INTO THE ELECTION.
BUT PEOPLE USE ELECTIONS AND
THIS NARRATIVE TO REALLY DISRUPT
AND DESTROY CONFIDENCE IN THE
ELECTION PROCESS.
LIKE YOU SAID, WE'VE DONE THREE
COUNTS ON THIS, THE INITIAL
COUNT, 100% HAND RECOUNT, AND
THEN DID A FINAL SCAN COUNT, AND
ALL THREE RESULTS WERE VERY
CLOSE.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, PRESIDENT
TRUMP CAME UP SHORT IN GEORGIA.
WE CHECKED AND RAN THE TRAP
LINES ON EVERY ALLEGATION THAT
WAS MADE.
I WROTE A TEN-PAGE LETTER TO
CONGRESS, AND I'VE HIGHLIGHTED
ALL THAT IN MY UPCOMING BOOK.
IT'S CALLED "INTEGRITY COUNTS"
BECAUSE INTEGRITY DOES COUNT.
IT ALWAYS HAS AND ALWAYS WILL.
>> I HOPE YOU'RE RIGHT.
I BELIEVE IN THAT MYSELF.
I WANT TO READ A SPECIFIC CLAIM
THAT TRUMP MAKES IN THIS LETTER,
SECRETARY.
HE SAYS, ENCLOSED IS A REPORT OF
43,000 ABSENTEE BALLOT VOTES
COUNTED IN DeKALB COUNTY THAT
VIOLATED THE CHAIN OF CUSTODY
RULES, MAKING THEM INVALID.
NOW, HE'S REFERRING, OF COURSE,
AS YOU KNOW, TO A REPORT FROM A
PRO-TRUMP WEBSITE WHICH DOES NOT
QUESTION THE VOTERS OR THE
BALLOTS THEMSELVES, RIGHT?
BUT THEY ACTUALLY -- THEIR
QUESTIONING IS ON HOW FAST THE
BALLOTS WERE ACTUALLY
TRANSPORTED.
>> WELL, EXACTLY.
>> GO AHEAD.
TELL ME YOUR RESPONSE.
>> AS SOON AS WE WERE NOTIFIED
OF THAT, WE BEGAN AN
INVESTIGATION SEVERAL WEEKS AGO
AND COMING OUT OF IT, THE FIRST
THING THAT YOU NOTICE IS THAT
THE DeKALB COUNTY ELECTION
OFFICIAL TOOK AN EXTENDED LEAVE
OF ABSENCE.
BUT WE HAVE AN ONGOING
INVESTIGATION OF THAT.
BUT TO YOUR POINT, THE BALLOTS
THEMSELVES WERE APPROVED AND ARE
LAWFUL BALLOTS.
BUT WHERE PROCESS IS VIOLATED,
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE INVESTIGATING
RIGHT NOW.
THAT WILL COME BEFORE THE STATE
ELECTION BOARD.
>> WHY DO YOU THINK TRUMP SENT
THIS LETTER NOW?
I MEAN AS OPPOSED TO -- YOU
KNOW, HE'S HAD 11 MONTHS, AND
OBVIOUSLY HE'S BEEN VERY VOCAL
IN THOSE 11 MONTHS, BUT WHY DO
YOU THINK HE'S SENT THIS LETTER
NOW?
>> WELL, HE'S BEEN LEANING INTO
AND PROPAGATING THE BIG LIE, AND
HE'S BEEN FUND-RAISING OFF THIS
ISSUE.
I KNOW HE'LL BE HERE IN GEORGIA
THIS COMING WEEKEND.
SO YOU'D HAVE TO ASK HIM WHAT
HIS MOTIVATIONS WERE.
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY, WE'VE
LOOKED AT EVERY SINGLE
ALLEGATION THAT'S BEEN MADE, AND
WE WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE TRUE AND ACCURATE RESULTS.
PEOPLE SAID THAT THERE WERE
THOUSANDS OF DEAD PEOPLE THAT
VOTED.
IT WAS LESS THAN A HANDFUL.
THEY ALSO TOLD US THAT OVER
66,000 UNDERAGE VOTERS VOTED.
THERE WERE ZERO.
THEY TALKED ABOUT UNREGISTERED
VOTERS VOTING.
THERE WERE NONE OF THAT.
SO WE HAVE REALLY MADE SURE THAT
WE'VE BEEN VERY THOUGHTFUL AND
THOROUGH IN OUR RESPONSES.
BUT PRESIDENT TRUMP CAME UP
SHORT IN GEORGIA.
>> SO LET ME ASK YOU OBVIOUSLY
YOU'RE LAYING ALL THIS OUT VERY
CLEARLY HERE TO ME IN OUR
CONVERSATION.
DO YOU PLAN TO OFFER A FORMAL
RESPONSE TO HIM, OR IS THIS --
IS THIS IT?
>> WELL, WHILE WE HAVE AN
ONGOING INVESTIGATION, WE'LL LET
THEM FINISH UP THEIR WORK, AND
THEY'LL REPORT TO THE STATE
ELECTION BOARD, AND THAT WILL BE
THE ANSWER.
>> SO I WANT TO ASK YOU
SOMETHING ELSE.
YOU TALK ABOUT INTEGRITY COUNTS
AND YOU'VE BEEN VERY CLEAR ABOUT
THAT, AND YOU HAVE STOOD UP
COURAGEOUSLY TO THE PRESIDENT
WHEN OTHERS WOULD NOT, CERTAINLY
NOT PUBLICLY.
BUT YOU DID SAY RECENTLY YOU
WOULDN'T COMPLY IF THE JANUARY
6th CONGRESSIONAL COMMITTEE
SUBPOENAS YOU.
OBVIOUSLY JANUARY 6th IS RELATED
TO THE FORMER PRESIDENT AND THE
BIG LIE.
SO EXPLAIN TO ME WHY YOU
WOULDN'T COMPLY IF THEY WANTED
TO TALK TO YOU.
JUST WHAT'S YOUR LOGIC?
>> WELL, WE WANTED TO SEE IF
THEY'RE GOING TO ISSUE A
SUBPOENA.
I FEEL LIKE I HAD A CONVERSATION
WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP.
IT'S A ONE-HOUR CONVERSATION.
IT'S ALL OUT THERE IN THE PUBLIC
DOMAIN.
WE REALLY RIGHT NOW ARE FOCUSED
ON IMPLEMENTING ALL THE ELECTION
LAW CHANGES THAT WE HAD WITH
S.B. 202.
WE HAVE A LOT OF ELECTIONS THIS
FALL WITH OUR MUNICIPAL
ELECTIONS.
WE HAVE WORK TO DO HERE, AND SO
IF THIS IS JUST GOING TO BE A
SIDESHOW UP IN WASHINGTON, WE
REALLY WANT TO BE FOCUSED ON
WHAT WE NEED TO DO HERE IN
GEORGIA.
>> ALL RIGHT.
WELL, I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME,
SECRETARY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS ALWAYS.
AGAIN, AS I SAID TO YOU BEFORE,
BEFORE WE EVEN CAME TO AIR, I